[Music]
now at first blush this may seem to be
another example of stupid pc word
policing but as you'll see that's not
exactly correct it is actually an
example of extremely maniacally stupid
pc word policing um stupid on multiple
levels and from every conceivable angle
the san francisco chronicle reports the
word chief will no longer be used in
reference to job titles in the san
francisco unified school district in an
effort school officials said to avoid
the words connotation with native
americans
in a statement to the newspaper a
spokeswoman for the district further
explained quote while there are many
opinions on the matter our leadership
team agreed that given that native
american members of our community have
expressed concern over the use of the
title we are no longer going to use it
they still haven't come up with a
replacement term yet which is why if you
go to the district's website you will
still find this hideous slur being used
in fact there's a whole section list
listing the division chiefs
and there are currently 13 chiefs
leading 13 tribes such as chief
technology officer melissa dodd chief
general counsel danielle houck
and chief of staff jill hugandik
what will we call these women now if
she's not chief jill hugendig what is
she and what word is safe leader head
captain master commander overlord these
words are all problematic too they're
either too militant too patriarchal or
they recall the troubling legacy of
slavery
maybe there should be no titles at all
maybe jill hogan dick is just jill
hugandik but then you've effectively
demoted all of these women
and they are almost all women by the way
12 of the 13 people leading the district
are women and what's the point of virtue
signaling with a leadership team
comprised of women
if you can't give them titles that
denote their leadership
this would also uh probably be a good
time to mention the minor detail that
chief
is not a native american word chief is
an english word which comes from french
which comes from latin
the french word is chef meaning head or
ruler or somebody in authority i'm not
sure how we got from there to chef as in
the guy with a funny hat in the kitchen
my etymological knowledge in this area
has already been exhausted but what i
can say for absolute certain is that
chief has been in usage since the 1300s
and wasn't applied to native americans
until sometime in the 1700s
english settlers had good reason to use
english words to describe native
americans namely the reason is that they
they spoke english and people generally
use words in the language they speak as
opposed to languages they don't speak
so the premise here is false and that's
enough to explain why this whole thing
is very stupid but as i said this is not
just stupid it's extremely maniacally
stupid and understand why i consider
that consider what they're actually
trying to do
if chief was a native american word
which it isn't but if it was then they
would be erasing native american
influence on the english language
they aren't doing that in this case
because the premise is false but they're
trying to
ostensibly for the sake of native
americans and supposedly at the behest
of native americans they are they think
erasing native american representation
in the english language
they believe this is an example of
native american language being adopted
by english-speaking people and their
goal is to
undo that influence
see the left always complains about
minorities being allegedly erased and
marginalized and yet that's exactly what
they're trying to do here again
when it comes to native americans
specifically the left has adopted sort
of this addition by subtraction strategy
while claiming that they want native
americans to be represented all they
have ever done for years is just erase
every mention or depiction or reference
or supposed reference to native
americans that they can find all of the
indian mascots and team names are being
changed every nod to indian culture is
being rooted out and cancelled most
recently a school in indiana came under
intense scrutiny for a half-time
ceremony involving students dressed in
traditional indian attire the school
been doing that for many years it was
supposed to be an homage to indian
culture and history
but it was deemed racist somehow for
reasons that are never made clear
all of these sorts of things have been
as the left says problematized
they've even snuffed out native american
depictions that were made by native
americans the lando lakes butter girl
famously canceled a couple of years ago
was partially the work of a native
american artist
and they got rid of that too
indeed in a culture obsessed with
representation
there's no question that native
americans are represented far less than
they used to be
i mean you used to find references to
them everywhere in many areas of life
even in children's games back in the
dark ages of the 90s as recently as then
kids would would play you know cowboys
and indians they were part of your games
they were just part of the culture they
were part of the language it was just
like
there was there was a certain presence
there and all of that is gone now
the representation bean counters have
seen to it that indian culture and
people are represented far less than
they used to be
and the thing is to me this is quite sad
because i actually find native american
history to be remarkable
and important one of my favorite books
of all time is empire of the summer moon
about the comanches whenever i'm
traveling with my family if there's a
native american museum nearby we always
visit it we go to native american
festivals and art exhibits my kids
currently have a teepee set up in their
gara in my garage
my son likes to run around the yard with
a spear that he made out of a stick and
a sharp rock now this all would be
considered cultural appropriation these
days i suppose you can call it that if
you want to i don't really care but the
history is fascinating
and um it's even more fascinating that i
as i'm told a racist right-wing white
supremacist ethnocentric bigot have more
interest in and respect for that history
than the culturally sensitive leftists
do
and but it's actually not that
surprising when you think about it of
course they want to erase native
american history they want to erase all
history
there's a reason they haven't replaced
most of the monuments and statues
they've torn down and when they do
replace them they're likely to put it to
put in its place a monument to some
unremarkable person who died a few years
ago like george floyd
they are not principally interested in
rewriting history or giving their own
version of it they do have their own
version that's the 1619 project but
really history itself
is an inconvenient reality to a leftist
they would rather erase the whole thing
there's too much in history especially
native american history but really all
history the whole history of the human
race
that's troublesome to the left and inc
incongruent with their claims and their
narratives
so they just don't want to talk about it
at all
their priority is to sever all people
from their history from history itself
and have us all live as though the world
itself came into being at the turn of
this current millennium
they don't want any of us to be rooted
too deeply or too connected with our
ancestors or too in touch with our past
because what they want
are blank slates
non-descript automatons that they can
mold and shape
as they see fit
that's what this is all about
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated